bonsoir martin mec coulis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
mort de cette jeune femme a servi
d'électrochoc semble-t-il au royaume uni
at il un un problème endémique de
violences faites aux femmes en grande
bretagne c'est une fille c'est un
événement dévastateur qui a eu un très
grand impact sur la population notamment
les femmes au royaume uni de poche le
cube
car la personne accusé de ce meurtre
d'état membre d'un groupe de police
d'élite
un garde des diplomates et des membres
du parlement
nopus la france et meurtres encore plus
choquant elle a été kidnappée et
assassinée et cela a suscité une énorme
colère de nombreuses veillées à la
bougie soirée des manifestations qui
techniquement sont illégales dans cette
période de confinement la police avait
donc reçu l'ordre d'interrompre ces
veillées ces manifestations cela a
suscité une position très forte une
seconde on a accusé la police d'avoir
manqué de présence d'esprit de d'avoir
empêché des femmes de manifester en paix
mais en sa patte de confinement cela
n'est pas autorisé c'était donc la cause
de
c'est confrontation entre la police et
la population et il y a beaucoup de
colère envers la police le secrétaire de
l'intérieur madame patel a défendu
fortement la police ce qui a mis
beaucoup de personnes en colère
un projet de loi très important est
examinée en ce moment par le parlement
visant à renforcer les pouvoirs de la
police en matière de manifestation car
il y en a de plus en plus et elle
dérange le trafic la vie par exemple où
les les opérations du parlement par
exemple cette loi augmenterait également
est la durée des condamnations pour les
viols par exemple et il y aurait des
officiers en civil qui pourrait se
rendre dans les bars et les boîtes de
nuit afin de protéger les femmes mais la
question et cela permettra-t-il de
protéger davantage les femmes car elles
craignent maintenant de sortir la nuit
dans les rues les plus solitaires de
londres pardonnez moi maintenant mes
collègues il ya souvent deux problèmes
dont on parle aussi beaucoup en france à
les violences donc faites aux femmes et
les violences entre guillemets un
policière on connaissait dans plusieurs
pays notamment la france
là ça fait deux thématiques de
problématiques qui sont reliées entre
elles
c'est vraiment une onde de choc et
provoqué au royaume uni où c'est
finalement un fait isolé le fait que ce
soit un policier qui est commis cette
agression ne fait que poly l'une pour
les jeux les faits avec un officier de
police et commis ce crime rend la chose
encore plus choquant citoyen lambda
dirais que c'est à la police deux
ce gérer la police devraient être
irréprochables devrait être certain que
les officiers de police respecte la loi
n'agresse pas des femmes donc c'est un
grand problème pour la police et cela a
des répercussions très profonde et
suscite beaucoup de colère notamment
occupé chez les femmes dans ce pays
c'est un tournant et la loi étudiée par
le parlement permettra de protéger
davantage les femmes et la police
acquerra plus de responsabilités dans la
protection des femmes par exemple
déployer des officiers en civil dans les
bars les boîtes de nuit en soirée et
cetera mais il est impossible pour la
police de protéger toutes les femmes de
londres c'est une ville très importante
et beaucoup de zones heures sont très
polis et les femmes demandent davantage
de protection et cette loi étudiée par
le parlement donnerait davantage de
pouvoirs à la police voulait que
pardonnez moi de mon couple et depuis
2016 il paraîtrait que seuls 5,5 pour
cent des viols signalés ont fait l'objet
d'une condamnation ce sont les chiffres
d'un quotidien evening standard ça veut
dire quoi que
le viol n'est pas vraiment pris en
considération au royaume uni il ya du
retard sur cette question dont les dans
les mentalités
s'agissant les viole la loi britannique
et fait qu'il est très difficile
d'obtenir une condamnation car la
défense mettra en avant le fait que la
femme était consentante et le parti de
la femme doit défendre l'idée que ce
n'est pas possible
donc c'est très difficile à prouver
nulle au avec cette nouvelle loi qui est
étudiée au parlement il sera plus facile
pour les fans femme d'obtenir une
condamnation contre un homme pour viol
mais l'opposition
l'idée qu' il pourrait y avoir des cas
de fausse accusation des femmes accusant
des hommes de viol car elles se sont
disputés elles veulent se venger et
c'est donc un problème culturel
il faut le croire qui dit la vérité le
gouvernement
johnson a tout de suite annoncé qu'il
allait dégager ces fonds supplémentaires
pour améliorer l'éclairage des rues a
ajouté des caméras de vidéosurveillance
et des patrouilles de police rend pensez
vous en avait parlé à l'instant à vous
entendre et à comprendre un petit peu la
situation au royaume uni est ce que
c'est vraiment la solution est ce que ce
n'est pas dans l'éducation dans les
esprits qu'il faut changer les choses
plus que les éclairages dans la rue oui
tout à fait l'éclairage public ne
résoudra pas ce problème
déployer davantage de policiers ne
le problème commence dans les écoles
ainsi que l'ont indiqué certains
éducateurs
il faut apprendre aux gars ont respecté
elle est finie et apprendre aux fille à
se comporter d'une façon qui ne soit pas
provoquant dis donc un tel apprentissage
ne peut commencer qu'à l'école est un
jeune homme il développera du respect
pour les femmes et sans se montrer sans
rester pour les femmes on peut
cela peut mener à de violent donc c'est
effectivement un problème culturel
c'est un problème entre les hommes et
les femmes et autant d'actes politiques
tant de manifestations de la part des
femmes qui demandent plus de protection
disant qu'on ne les écoute pas qu'elles
sont mises de côté que la loose
la police est en majorité constituée
d'hommes que l'establishment politique
se compose d'hommes les femmes demande
qu'on prenne davantage en compte le
point de vue des femmes
mais pour moi effectivement le problème
ne peut pas être résolu avec plus
d'éclat à ce public plus de policiers
cela doit commencer à l'école avec les
garçons et les filles merci martin mc
colis anaïs politique d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir